foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Sunday and it's movie time yeah I gotta
make sure I'm in a video Yeah and get in
this video I might be in a video next to
it
that never gets old I just like it just
it just tickles me thinking about you
popping into the video Next Door on
YouTube yeah like hey they're like who
the [__] are you like Hollywood Squares
yeah
get out of my video Paul wind yeah so
it's just kind of like that all right
that can be only one yeah that's what
they say that can be only one and here
look at this yes this one was from a
good Louis Hernandez a great uh friend
of the show for years and years been a
really good contributor by sending us
[__] Blu-rays and look how shiny it
is that's a steel book like steel book
it's got a damp clear plastic slip cover
it's got trading cards in it it's in 4k
and it's it's a top-notch it's a
top-notch uh uh edition of that it's
it's really nice man appreciate it yeah
and this is a great movie uh saw it in
the theater when it came out as a kid
I remember liking it I think I may have
seen it twice and while it was in the
theater
and um it held up it's good I didn't
realize it was a Canon film I did not
realize
because he was like oh I have to wear
this yeah yeah because it was it was um
real good for a Canon film Canon was
always entertaining but a lot of it was
schlock but you knew where you're
getting into you know uh but no this is
a Canon film it's it's uh one of their
better films as far as I'm concerned
it's a great idea yeah great and the
concept is great yeah it's got a real
good adage I'll let Jenny fill you in on
what on on the story
so yeah so Highlander this came out in
1986. now I feel like I did not see this
in the theater
but I did see it on cable once or twice
and I remember enjoying it although it
wasn't like super because it's kind of
more I guess it's like a fantasy
um you know the adventure kind of film
which wasn't usually my favorite thing
but seeing it again I was like wow this
really is like a cool ass movie and I
feel like
um it it didn't do very well at the box
office I think it cost 19 million to
make and a million of that was Sean
Connery salary yeah so you know our New
Harmony Bridges
I mean even though he only shot like
seven he only had to shoot for seven
days yeah so it's like a million dollars
for a week that's not bad not bad
um but you're against what you're
praying for
right but yeah so uh so it only caused
and it didn't even make its money back
like it attempted the box office yeah oh
man we saw it like I said we loved it
but well it was one of those ones and I
feel like this happened a lot in the 80s
that it came out in the theater and
everyone was like meh or they didn't go
see it but then when it came out on VHS
then everybody was into it like it would
get around by word of mouth and that's
definitely what happened on this one
this one got so much play like after it
came out on VHS that it ended up
spawning a whole entire franchise there
was like there was a second movie which
is terrible uh third movie which is also
terrible that I think is better than the
second one there was a TV series which
actually a lot of people think is really
good
um and there was an animated series
these uh there was a couple video games
so it's like and they're talking about
doing a remake
um you know they even have cast uh Henry
Cavill who is supposed to be which I
think he'd be good I think
um who's gonna be the main Highlander
guy but yeah so they've been talking
about remaking it this is one of those
movies
it's just it's so 80s that it hurts but
then in other ways like it's almost like
Timeless is that a weird thing to say
well I think a lot of it has to do with
its practical effects
so they've aged well it waged a lot
better than CG because the special
effects that you're seeing are kind of
artistic artistic lightning bolts and
[__]
it's a fantasy movie yeah so the tone is
correct
um there's some scenes that have uh like
some good miniature work
you know the sign that the kurgan is
cutting down with a woman tied to it at
the end
um
caps the castles collapse and you know
they're falling apart because you hit it
real too hard with a sword I don't
understand well the swords are magical
that's right
and uh just
cool outfits uh it's just a good movie
but I think I think one of the things
that really shines is is the edit of
this movie it's very fast paced but it
has given you all the details that you
need to know
there's an element of romance in the
movie yeah there is actually yeah which
is for a dude flick that's normally not
there but they're trying to be you try
to be sensitive with this [__] movie
Just but not overly sensitive can't
can't be overly sensitive yeah just
sensitive enough not too many emotions
yeah just a little bit of emotions and
watching this thing and I was going like
you know what
this is a Neil Breen movie
these are the movies that Neil Breen was
trying to write movies about dudes with
Supernatural Powers all these women
loving on him but no I can't sleep with
you baby you know because I live forever
and you'll turn into it yeah yeah right
yeah yeah all kind and uh once I've
completed my mission I will save mankind
you know and and uh all these cheesy
kind of like one-liner type Powers you
know and statements are lots of
different where you from from lots of
different places you know like that's a
big deal you know it's just all kinds of
[__]
about it is is very breen-esque which I
think brain was ripping this off trying
to rip these movies off he wanted to be
the Highlander I think or something like
that
yeah now that you mentioned it I think
yeah it probably was very influenced by
obviously I think this movie actually
influenced all of his movies yeah I'm
sure yeah I think the reason that it
works and maybe I don't know we'll get
into this a little bit because
um you know the main role obviously the
Highlander whose name is Connor McLeod
actually left his real name like I think
in the present day timeline he's named
Russell Nash but um so he's played by
Christopher Lambert or Lambert if you
would rather
um who interestingly I don't know if you
knew this but when they hired him to be
the lead in this it was actually
supposed to be Kurt Russell
um that would have worked yeah uh he was
actually supposed to be in it but I
think he had to pull out like uh in
pre-production I would have loved that
but yeah that's that's who I think was
there was a couple other actors I think
that were up for it but I think Kurt
Russell was the one that was
misassociated with it but they actually
they saw Christopher Lambert in uh
greystoke that Tarzan movie yeah and uh
they're like oh my God he was great in
that it's like the book that's like
that's who we want so they got him but
they didn't realize that he couldn't
speak English because he was born in the
United States but his parents were
French diplomats so he actually grew up
in France and Switzerland and his
English was almost non-existent so he
actually had to work with a dialogue
coach for this movie for a few months
like to get enough English to be and I
think he did okay yeah you know what I
mean you wouldn't really know that he
couldn't speak any English
got an accent well yeah yeah English but
I mean I knew he was French anyway so it
was just kind of like I was like
obviously he's got a French accent
although he's playing a Scottish person
and everybody brings this up so it's
like they got a french guy to play a
Scottish guy and then they got a real
Scottish guy Sean Connery to play an
Egyptian playing playing a Spaniard
I was like I'm not really sure why they
couldn't have just like flipped that or
because I don't think it would have made
a big difference to the story like for
sure like Sean Connery's character
um well he absolutely did not have to be
Egyptian or Spanish he could have just
been Scottish and really the Highlight
well I guess the reason it was called
Highlander well but they didn't but that
wasn't the original name of the movie
the original name of the movie matter of
fact was The Dark Knight which obviously
they can't call it that no they're
talking about the kurgan yeah it was
Clancy Brown yeah because he was just
called the knight in the original uh
version Brown kind of steals this show
in this moment I love Clancy Brown so
much he is so awesome
he's also he's the guy from Starship
Troopers he was he was in Starship
Troopers yeah he played the monster in
the bride yeah he's also the voice of Mr
Krabs from SpongeBob SquarePants yeah
but he's a good character in this he's
uh he's [__] huge I didn't realize
he's that tall yeah he's a massive
mother he's [__] tall
um
he's not real massive you know not he's
not like Arnold or anything Arnold that
wasn't that tall but he's just imposing
a big tall dude with some Mass on him
and uh he can cover a lot of distance
pretty quickly during those swords
fights you know because big old long
lanky legs
and uh kind of an intimidating presence
for a guy who's so [__] crazy and
immature I mean he's very immature they
made him kind of like psycho yeah kind
of like a heavy metal yeah dude yeah
which like I said in the original
because this story was initially written
by a guy named Gregory Wyden and he
actually wrote the script for this when
he was still in film school I think yeah
and in the original story which was like
a lot more serious like the Knight
character was like a lot more serious
and a lot more kind of like uh burdened
I guess like by his immortality but when
they went into the movie they were like
let's just have fun with it I guess and
then he just went like totally over the
top and I think like to a large extent
it works yeah it now I saw this in the
theater when I was a kid and yeah I was
a bit I was a big metal fan and I didn't
see he was not
you could probably say in general he was
supposed to have like a heavy metal
image but it wasn't mainstream metal
during that time mainstream metal was
like [__] docking and definitely he
was like black metal yeah you know like
satanic metal looking uh almost because
someone like semi-goth bondage punk rock
kind of they always they always dress
bad guys like that yeah these movies
yeah he looked real good I thought he
looked cool yeah although I first saw
him and the first thing I thought was
like oh it look it looked like somebody
inflated Lux interior yeah
we had torn up fingerless gloves and
[__] one of his sleeves was missing
on his leather jacket kind of like out
of them uh Commando no that was [__]
Mad Max oh right right yeah at a road
warrior one of his sleeves was missing
because they ripped it off remember yeah
his arm was outside the car window and
they pulled it off but he had in the
rest of the movie he's just got one
sleeve on his jacket what do you think I
can afford another sleeve yeah it is
he's got that there's a little bit of
chainmail Ale in it and that sword
it was I thought it was a good outfit it
was much better than Lambert's outfits
especially in the opening scene where he
does a sword fight with this guy who
ends up killing him down the parking lot
so I remember seeing that for the first
time you know and I was going what the
[__] is going on what the [__] is going
on with this movie you know what I mean
the lightning bolts of [__] and dead
bodies coming up headless dead bodies
well um in that one
he's got a
tan overcoat and just jeans and white
sneakers running around and he's
fighting a dude in a suit and it just
looked to me I thought it was a poor
choice of of costumes for that scene he
should have been in like a suit also I
thought it would look like yeah I think
that would have looked a lot cooler you
know put him in something a little more
slick because yeah he kind of looked
like a bum like a flasher like for at
the Greyhound station a little bit he
looked like a poser he looked like a
dude he really couldn't afford any
clothes and he just happened to find a
cool trench coat put it on
yeah like and there was a lot of that
going on when in the 80s if you're a
teenager you couldn't get any cool
clothes so he looked like a teenager
from the 80s he did kind of now that you
mentioned it but then you find out
he's a [__] multi-multi-millionaire
so he should have had his choice of
clothes that [__] should have
been you know dressed to the nines and
he was at a game
so like a wrestling man yeah so there's
no reason for him and he had to have the
Overcoat to hide the sword yeah that's
what Benja said he hadn't had a sword
somewhere yeah but the thing is is that
the rest of the [__] that he was wearing
didn't match the Overcoat so but then
the dude he was fighting was [__] it
was it all matched and there was a
visually it didn't quite work for me
that seat even though it was a good seat
but the costume didn't work although
that was just one that was the one of
the only things that bothered me about
that movie was that costume selection
right there the rest of the movie man I
liked it
yeah because it's I I feel like it is
kind of a little bit hard to take like a
Immortal Warrior seriously when he's got
like white sneakers white sneakers and
jeans I mean looking out yeah it just
didn't
yeah it couldn't take wait big ones
that's a little bit I mean at least he
wasn't wearing like cargo shorts or
something but still or Crocs yeah
he should have been [__] styling his
his the the sword that he was had that
he had was worth five million they said
I thought they just said a million
dollars just a million okay that
Japanese story that was the one that was
Sean Connery story yeah like to start
with and after Sean Connery got beheaded
uh spoiler alert then um for a movie
from 1986. yeah
um but you know what I mean yeah he took
his sword like yeah because that was
like his mentor you know yeah the guy
that told him that he was Immortal
so uh so yeah now another thing that I
did not realize until we were watching
it again last night was that this was
directed by Russell Mulcahy now if you
don't know who Russell Mulkey he is he's
an Australian dude this was I think
maybe the second movie he directed the
first one he did was actually kind of a
fun uh cult horror movie called
Razorback about like a killer boar I
think it was which is actually pretty
fun
but I knew him because he directed
pretty much all the iconic 80s MTV music
videos that you remember he direct he
worked a lot with Duran Duran that's how
I knew who he was because I was like a
big fan of his like he did Hungry Like
the Wolf and he had the wild boys and he
did all that and I didn't realize this
but he also directed really iconic music
videos the Buggles Video Killed the
Radio storm star which if you didn't
know was the first video that was ever
shown on MTV I watched it happen man
yeah in California it was called there's
a service called on TV and the first day
that [__] MTV came on we were waiting
for it to come on and they had a little
bit of a VJ in the intro or what the
[__] is this going to be and then they
played that it was the first music video
ever and I didn't know what to make of
it
yeah I wasn't quite sure what it was I
was like is it going to be a movie it's
weird you know yeah it's a song but it's
like a little movie that's a song and I
just tried to picture what that was back
in those days yeah a movie that's like a
song
in a few minutes you understand you see
a couple of them you know what you're
talking about yeah you're right but yeah
he directed that one he also directed uh
turning Japanese by the vapors yeah
Gypsy by Fleetwood Mac Oh yeah I'm still
standing uh Elton John uh he did making
plans for Nigel by XTC uh he did some
Human League oh yeah uh Culture Club so
pretty much most of the like I said he
worked with Duran Duran a lot I think he
not only did I know he did Hungry Like
the Wolf and wild boys I think he might
have also done like Union of the snake
and Rio and like all those kind of ones
that were sort of like similar like that
voice was a good video I really like
that Mad Max theme to it right yeah
which explains why the kurgan had that
damn Mad Max jacket on yeah because it
was all well I mean that was very trendy
very interesting there was a lot of that
stuff going on in movies in the 1980s
but uh but yeah so um so you can
definitely tell that this movie was made
by somebody that was Prim primarily like
a music video director you can tell like
in the edit you can tell in the way the
shots are composed are very like an 80s
music video and I don't mean that like
disparagingly I mean that like in a good
way and also the way that music is used
in this and I feel like you can't talk
about Highlander without talking about
the soundtrack queen queen yeah and
they're good songs good Queen songs yeah
yeah okay
first time I saw a queen soundtrack was
you know Flash Gordon I loved it but
there were really only like two songs on
it that were full Queen songs
and there weren't even really full songs
they were like half songs you know but
uh this one has full songs and they were
hits I remember them being on the radio
he wants to live forever that was a huge
hit yeah I think Roger Taylor wrote that
one yeah or no Brian maybe Brian May
wrote that one and then uh
then uh the damn Highlander theme song
something about the Protectors of the
universe or what the [__] was that uh
[__] princess of the universe yeah yeah
that was also on the radio and they
played they just
and then whenever there's incidental
music like somebody turns a radio on you
know in the car it's got Queens it's all
Queen yeah and it's clean and I think
there must have been it must this stuff
must have been associated with a new
Queen album that was coming out around
this one what happened was that they um
that queen or asked uh actually that was
another one they were gonna ask Duran
Duran they'll do the music for it but I
guess they didn't do it for whatever
reason but so they asked Queen to do one
song for the movie but when they went
and screened the movie they liked it so
much that they wrote like a [__] ton of
songs like for the movie and like each
of them wrote different ones like for
different scenes they particularly liked
and they ended up using like a whole
bunch of them now they never did put out
like a soundtrack album there is a score
which Michael came and did Michael
Cayman has done like a [__] ton of
[__] uh his movie scores as well but
um and his score in this is good too but
the Queen songs they never did do a
soundtrack but they released all of the
songs pretty much like on other ones of
their albums you know what I mean yeah
so but they but they were songs were
written for this movie yeah the songs
are that good they don't sound like just
some knockoff song made for a movie I
mean they they're just you know I mean
they were hits yeah they were hits they
were good yeah Ben said a different kind
of magic was the album yeah that's right
okay yeah because that was what one of
the songs was called yeah they did put
about I think the only one that hasn't
been released is there's one point where
um there's a version that they do New
York New York they do a cover of that
like which is great
um but I don't think they ever put that
out as a single but most of the other uh
songs were put out as singles or were
put out on their other albums you know
what I mean but they were actually like
written for this movie because they were
really into it and it's interesting
because I don't know I think the Queen
music works really well like with this
because the movie is I don't want to say
it's like it's not really over the top
or outrageous or anything like that but
it does have that sort of
a little bit like outlandish kind of 80s
over-the-top kind of like it's right
it's a fantasy tone kind of like legend
or something or yeah uh what was the
[__] what was the one with a little
kid flying around on the damn Dragon not
that bad but during this time Never
Ending Story Never Ending Story during
that time there was a lot of fantasy
movies that came out yeah fantasy was
big in the 80s yeah you know even
Labyrinth was like that yeah uh which
has another [__] fantastic flick God
damn it but this had its own tone it was
a fantasy flick
that could fit in with the other ones
but it was live action kind of more
grounded in reality
and it was supposed to be like hip and
cool you know
rock you know yeah metal type inspired
type thing you know and it was just uh
it worked I thought it was a good time
it was real good yeah it kind of all
worked together yeah they were because
some of the shit's happening back in
Ireland or Scotland yeah back in 1500
but I was looking nice as I said that's
1500s that looks more like [__] 900
or 1000 because it looked [__]
medieval as [__] but um
some of it's happening in the past so
the movie into constantly doing
flashbacks to explain why he just did
something
you know why he didn't go for that woman
well later on you find out you know
um so it's blending what would be the
present and the past together in the
same story so you have medieval stuff
and modern stuff you have technology and
you have magic
so that they were trying to synthesize
it all together I think it worked yeah I
think it worked and it's hard to believe
that this is a Canon film because Canada
normally would [__] it up
they would [__] something up sometimes
they [__] things up and really
entertaining with you yeah yeah as we as
we've seen but you know what I mean just
good director good editor good editing a
good story uh decent acting and you know
it was it was the kind of acting that
brought the the tone that they were
looking for
it was cool they even had a damn
survivalist in there [__] jump out
with supposedly a Mach 10 but it it
mysteriously turns into an Uzi and he
[__] lights up the kurgan and the
kurgan [__] sticks him with a sword
is holding him up then he he survives
though he's telling the cops he's at the
hospital
tells the whole story I loaded enough to
kill a rhino
he wasn't being charged because he
legally owned all that stuff but now the
technical technical uh uh note on the
side here
in that scene they showed that [__]
cool ass Ingram Mack 10.
sitting next to him in his he's driving
around in a [__] Trans Am or Pontiac
Trans Am or a Firebird or something just
had the bird on a hood it was a white
one I think
ah
it's a Mac 10 when they show up and when
he jumps out and shoots the guy it's a
it's a it's an Uzi
which is about the similar size and
shape but it's a totally different the
reason why they did that is because Mac
10s tended to be 45 automatics
45 blanks didn't have enough Force to
knock the bolt back and cycle it full
auto
and uh so what they usually do is
substitute Mac tents for Uzis because
they were nine millimeter nine
millimeter blanks had higher pressure so
they could cycle the actions that's why
they did it by the way they just show it
as a Uzi you know somebody had to see I
always kind of wonder about that kind of
stuff it had to be a Mach 10 in
somebody's mind because that's kind of
like a similar thing to like why didn't
they just switch the characters to the
nationalities that the actors were yeah
instead of you know because it wouldn't
really have made a difference to the
story and that wouldn't have made a
difference why didn't they just have it
be the same gun like switching them out
the only thing I'm thinking that happens
a lot of movies the only thing I can
think of of is there may have been a
fetish for the Mac 10 at that time which
I that probably kind of was
maybe it had something to do with maybe
crosstalk was going to be there because
Snake Plissken carried a Mac 10. maybe
it was just maybe they were supposed to
be like I could just play crossover
University it might have been an Easter
egg having to do with right oh yeah
maybe I didn't think about that it might
have been an Easter egg that that the
the survivalist was a guy like snake
pliskin that's probably what the shout
out might have been
and maybe it was it would have made more
sense if
if kressel was in the movie yeah you
know crossword fans would go oh he's
like ah I see what you did that's what
you did there it wasn't the same gun
though
um
snake listen smack 10 was suppressed and
had a scope on the suppressor made no
sense it looked cool but that makes no
sense
well it's a movie it's a movie it's a
movie it's just supposed to look cool no
one cares if it's like you know what I
mean like other than a couple people
like you yeah slasher Fred said I love
how this movie plays like a mystery
because we don't know anything about
Conor MacLeod until we see the flashback
scenes yeah I I'm kind of wondering if
maybe that's why it didn't do that well
at the box office because this is a
movie that I mean you have to think it's
like and now everybody knows what the
[__] Highlander is about right it's
about an immortal Warriors like all
throughout you know and they try to
behead each other so because there's so
there can be only one yada yada yeah you
know that's pretty much the gist of it
but I kind of feel like in 1986 you
wouldn't have known anything about what
the movie was about so you just go and
you watch it you're just like what the
actual [__] is going on like why is he
who is this guy and why does he suddenly
have long hair and he's in the Scottish
Highlands and yeah 1500 now and it's
like because they don't really explain
it you know what I mean like you have to
wait until like almost the middle before
you really figure out what's going on
yeah you know in this day and age you're
watching this movie you know basically
what the story is yeah most people do
but when I saw it in the theater I had
no idea what it was yeah no idea and uh
there's all these reveals that were
happening so for somebody that is going
into a blind you're just seeing these
reveals and it's on the big screen it's
new and it's it's blowing your mind
because you've never heard of this story
before right you know it's not an old
story it's a news story
so it was effective I liked it and
everybody in the theater seemed to like
it so I don't know why it flopped
yeah maybe it was just kind of like I
don't know if it was just it was just
one of those things you know it was just
one of those things that just didn't
connect with enough people but then the
thing about it is that the Home Video
Market it really took off yeah like once
it came out on VHS and like I said
probably got you know word of mouth and
things like that but for whatever reason
people didn't go see it in the theater
because I don't know particularly back
in the 80s I'm not real sure how much
overlap there was between like theater
going audiences and VHS rental audiences
I mean I'm sure there was quite a large
overlap but I don't know
if you may be people that would like
rent things you know that wouldn't have
necessarily have gone to see them in the
theater and vice versa you know what I
mean so I don't really know
um Trey says I need to watch this one
day I've never seen it I saw the sequel
though now I saw the sequel once I don't
remember anything about it but pretty
much I watched a couple reviews of the
sequel just so I could see like what the
what the kind of prevailing attitude
about it was and most people hated the
sequel which was called um you know it
was just called uh Highlander the
quickening
and because I feel like the second one
went back and like kind of [__] on the
mythology of the first one because the
first one I mean they kind of set it up
I mean it's the whole [__] tagline of
the movie right it's like there can be
only one there's only supposed to be one
like at the end when they do the whole
meeting they all all the you know ones
that are all the Immortals that are left
they all get drawn to this one place and
they do the Gathering and then you know
they have to fight each other to the
death and behead until there's only one
left right and then they get the prize
like whatever that is yeah and they
absorb each other's power right so they
get stronger they kill yeah but um but I
feel like the the sequel just like went
back and was like oh no never mind like
now we can have a bunch of them and yeah
[__] like that so I think it kind of
like went back and [__] on the mythology
and then I think the third one went back
and said um never mind about the second
one we're just gonna pretend that didn't
exist right you know what I mean so it
was like you know they retconned that
one yeah Ben says uh the sequel is hot
garbage famously bad good yeah uh Ben
also says have you read the Highlander
novelization or seen any of the TV
episodes I haven't but I've heard like a
lot of good things about the TV series a
lot of people seem to like the TV series
um Christopher Lambert was not in the TV
series I think he was in the first one
but they actually posited that it was
like another guy like from Clan McLeod
that was like you know what I mean it
was like in the same universe I think it
was Adrian Paul was the actor that
played him and a lot of people really
did like that one some people think that
the um the series was actually better
than the movies uh you know I can't
really speak to that one well my dad
says that about Stargate
yeah across a flick I like Stargate I've
never seen the uh this area they've
never seen the series my dad says oh man
this series is good you know my dad he
would defend Target
I like that one so when he got that
thing on his head he got black guy with
that thing on his forehead he knew his
name he knew all the backstories and I
was like I don't know who that is
some magical guy I I've never seen it
but he my dad said that was a great
series he loved it he liked it better
than Star Trek Star Trek he liked it
better than Star Trek next Generation
get around to it one of these days I
really like I don't love the star game I
did my dad's voice there but uh yeah I
haven't done my dad's voice in a long
time I know right you just talked to him
on the phone the other day yeah yeah
Trey also mentioned Russell Mulkey he
worked a whole bunch with Duran Duran
yeah I brought that up earlier because I
said that's how I knew exactly who he
was like when we were watching the movie
last night I'm like oh my God Rest the
ball okay he did all the Duran Duran
videos because I used to have um you
know back in the 80s I used to have all
the uh like Duran Duran like video
compilations that they put out like on
VHS and a lot of times they had like um
when they did documentaries about the
making of the videos like they had
Russell Mulcahy and they were like
talking about them because he was kind
of known for doing all their real iconic
videos in the 1980s
um somebody says the Sleepy Hollow
series wait a minute where was it uh
uh so I loved how the TV series Sleepy
Hollow has many similarities to
Highlander you have a guy from the old
centuries who wakes up in present day
and the first season also has Clancy
Brown yeah I kind of feel like I don't
know how
knew this idea was in the 80s but I kind
of feel like it was it was fairly new I
feel like because like you said you kind
of had a thing where
I don't know this is gonna sound a
little bit off the wall and I only just
now the second thought of this it kind
of reminds me of The Outlaw of Gore like
which was like a series of books from I
don't remember when they were written
but they made like a bunch of shitty
movies like um especially I think made
them in Italy and stuff one of them was
on Mystery Science Theater
and had Jack Palance in it and it's
awful and amazing but that was kind of
about a guy who was like a regular
modern day guy but then like every now
and then he would get sucked back to
this other dimension that was kind of
like I don't know if it was medieval or
it was pre-medieval I feel like it was
like a fantasy kind of Kingdom like
Conan land and uh he would get called
back there like when anybody needed help
or anything so it's I don't know I feel
like it was that kind of thing where it
was like a combo of like past and
present like it's doing sort of the same
thing but I don't know it's just I I
don't
I don't love this movie as much as some
people do but it really I haven't seen
it for like a really long time and I
feel like watching it again like it
really holds up like it's a lot of fun
yeah you know what I mean I can see why
I can see why it wasn't like a huge
success when it came out in the theaters
at the time but I can also see why it
very very quickly developed a cult
classic to an extent where it had this
whole extended universe and mythology
and there's like but I think there's
even a [__] anime yeah well I gotta
say I think maybe although you there you
like some Macho ass movies you know
they're like Predator one you know I've
never known a woman that [__] did not
like predator and that that movie is
just [__] pure testosterone everybody
likes Predator because it's a [__]
great flick all right yeah that's what I
mean everybody likes Predator I've never
met anybody maybe one of the reasons why
there's something about this movie
that's that that's very male
a almost teenage male it's very much a
neo-breen type situation
where you're identifying with these lead
characters you're identifying more with
these Immortals okay yeah and these
Immortals are being loved on by all
these [__] beautiful women of
different Generations across time see
it's kind of a male fantasy
yeah all right very much so and there
there are there's romance elements into
a tragic romance in it
but it's called the kind of romance
stories that guys accept
you know what I mean they're like yeah
yeah that's that I'll allow it yeah
because
not to be not not to like downplay men's
sense of [__] romance it's just that
they're superficial it's superficial man
doesn't have to wallow in it especially
teenage boys they just need to be told
that there was a tragedy it's shown it
they don't wall around it they just move
on okay that's why he's doing this it's
just a very male telling of the story if
you ask me yeah it's like that's what
the market was
so it's a dude flick it is it's a dude
it's a dude fan there's a lot of sword
fighting yeah Immortals like you said
loving on all the ladies yeah and it has
that kind of thing where it's like I
can't be with you baby because I live
forever I am so [__] hot I just can't
be with you your heart would be broken
when you die because I don't die I'm
[__] superhuman I'm here to save the
world I gotta kill these other badasses
and until there's only one of them and
then I become the badass that because
that runs the world with god-like powers
can read people's minds can bring the
[__] world's leaders together and all
the scientists that's some Neil Breen
[__] that's a real breed yeah Neil Breen
wishes that he was yeah
that is a Neo green male fantasy okay
he's going off on the [__] yeah
hahaha
oh my God yeah but well can we talk a
little bit about like the kind of little
romance bit that goes on in it because I
mean Christopher Lambert he's very
um wooden yeah I was gonna say stoic
he's wooden
um but yeah in a way
I you know I get it it's like like I
said he couldn't really speak English
when he got the so he maybe was like a
little bit you know insecure about that
but in a way I think it works for this
character because he really does come
across as somebody that's like lived for
hundreds of years and they're just like
sick of this [__] he does kind of come
across he comes off as creepy though too
a little bit comes across a little bit a
little bit creepy like he's uh you don't
know if he's if he's scam and he there's
a neo-breen quality too yeah there is
there's a deal it's just kind of creepy
but um but yeah can we talk about like
well because he didn't actually know
that he was an immortal that he was the
Highlander he had to discover he had to
discover it like later like when Sean
Connery told him about it that's great
well he gets killed by the kurgan by um
by Clancy Brown's character like back in
1536 or whatever yeah right through the
right through the midriff yeah he gets
stabbed through and he's like oh [__]
I'm dead but then he's like oh wait I'm
not dead and then like he wakes up again
and I love the way everybody in his town
who've known him for years and years
like since he was born were like witch
get the [__] out like even his wife is
just kind of like burn him and I was
like damn she was the one leading the
charge right what do you mean we can't
burn him [__] that [__] well they
thought he'd gotten in League with the
devil that that wasn't him anymore right
he was possessed basically by the devil
is what they would think yeah they were
gonna burn him at the stake for Christ's
sake yeah until finally like just the
one reasonable person left and it was
just like bro you just you just leave
you know what I mean because otherwise
his cousin saved him and got him out of
there yeah just said we're gonna banish
him like you guys settle down then he
ends up with the like love of his life
this uh cute little Scottish chick she
said yeah Heather he called her Blossom
though
and uh that was really sad that really
kind of got me in the feels well that
was that was the idea and uh and like
say that would that's like a good
romance angle for teenage boys they they
can relate to that they're like oh well
because it's like he couldn't have kids
although in the original story I will
note um he could have children like he
had and he had a bunch of them like over
the years as you would like if you lived
forever but um in the in the universe of
the movie he can't actually have
children yeah so um so but he stayed
with Heather
until she died died of old age until she
died of old age yeah and then like he
lived for hundreds of years and every
year on her birthday he would go and
like light a candle at a church for her
because he promised that he would and I
was like oh that's really nice and she
saw the big fight between the kurgan and
Ramirez
and kurgan killed Ramirez
and she was in the in the castle it was
falling it was falling apart
and then he must have told her that
um explained to her that he was an
immoral because she seemed seeming she
doesn't come out and say that she knows
but
I guess she does no well I mean you'd
think that she would be still young
figured it out like she's like hey I'm
like 80 years old and I look like an old
hag and you still look all hot and [__]
right and then in the 20th century
[__] couple hundred years later finds
out the kurgan tells me yeah I killed
Ramirez he died like a pig you know and
uh raped his woman before his blood was
even dry and [__] he goes oh wait a
minute I see that wasn't his woman that
was your woman wasn't it
she never told you yeah maybe she
secretly wished I'd come back yeah that
guy's it [__] [__] with his mom
that's it was an ass hat
but uh no [__] little blossom didn't
tell him
didn't tell her which might have been
the right move because it was just
paying Tim
well I thought I mean they didn't like
explicitly go into that but I thought
that was the reason why she didn't say
anything yeah was because it would have
like yeah and so she's like well she
absorbed the damage yeah I'm just gonna
keep that to myself and she just because
she wanted I guess she just wanted to
put on a Blake a brave face for him yeah
well Ramirez got killed that was that
was bad enough yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying she wanna like compound the
[__] pain that he was going through
Ben says sword fight experts claim the
duels in Highlander are terrible
um that's theatrical well that would be
I mean the guy that uh that
choreographed them was one of the stunt
doubles for Darth Vader and he also did
um I think he also did like the
choreographed sword fights in like a
bunch of other like fantasy movies like
really good ones and stuff they're just
it's just theatrical yeah yeah it just
to look good on camera that's what
looked good on cameras not what those
guys really used no you know well yeah I
mean it's like two different things
slasher friends that I read that the op
the original opening was supposed to
take place at a hockey game it was
actually
um but I think the NH the NHL protested
because they said oh well the whole
point of you opening on a hockey game
like it originally was supposed to be
was you're supposed to show like it's
supposed to show like violence and
everybody's sitting around watching it
like a gladiatorial kind of thing and I
guess like the NHL were like well we
don't want to associate like the game
with violence even though that's totally
why everybody watches it but so yeah
they had to like change it to like a
wrestling match and actually it didn't
even really register with me I'm like
why do we have why are we at a wrestling
match I just thought that was kind of
but then when I thought about it later I
was just like oh yeah I guess that was
kind of why because I wasn't really you
know Ben said the Highlander anime is
pretty good Highlander the search for
vengeance yeah I've heard that a lot of
the media that came out like in the you
know that's kind of like all the
offshoot media is actually like pretty
good
um it's probably just the second movie
that contained it tarnish to the brand
name everybody says that the other stuff
is pretty good
yeah and like I said a lot of people
like the TV series even better than the
movies I remember people liking the TV
series that was TNT wasn't it I didn't
they didn't that was it I
remember it being on I don't think I
ever saw it though I mean I might even
Turner Broadcasting System or what was
the name I might have it's one of the
old it was kind of I think that was one
of the off-brand cable channels did that
Turner Broadcasting systems yeah I
thought it was something like that too
but I could totally be wrong uh Ben said
the other thing that has never been
explained is all the Immortals are
supposed to be foundlings no woman ever
gives birth to one that's why the weird
thing in the second one with alien
planet yeah I thought that was one of
the things that pissed off like uh fans
of the first movie and the second one
was that they were like oh by the way
the Immortals are like aliens
so they had to take it that route right
but yeah well yeah they should have left
it like the Lord of the Rings route
where it's just magic
yeah it's like you don't have to over
explain it they don't got to be from
outer space or nothing like that because
then it went like more sci-fi and I kind
of feel like it was better like as a
more like pure like sword and sandal
fantasy type of thing 70s and 80s I said
it was USA Network USA Network I knew it
was one of the one of those that was the
same one it would have like [__]
Walker Texas Ranger and just [__] on it
but uh you know 70s and 80s they were
just wide open for magic there's no
reason to have any kind of explanation
no magic bro yeah magic magic period
like you know you you saw The Hobbit you
know you saw Lord of the Rings I saw the
cartoons but that's what it is Dungeons
and Dragons man just like that okay yeah
we're gonna go with that
there's no reason to explain anything
yeah I mean as long as I mean when
you're doing fantasy or Supernatural or
anything like that as long as the rules
of your Universe are consistent you
don't need to explain [__] there was
another fantasy one that was more sci-fi
than this one
I think came out before this that I
remember I saw in the theater I think
twice matinee
for the Summers visiting my dad in
Mississippi
and I remember liking it I don't know if
it stands up to if it stands up to the
test of time it was called crawl yeah
yeah yeah I remember liking it it was it
was it wasn't great it was like 75
[__] cool with like 25 of like come
on why'd they do that but you know I
mean it was a weird mixture of stuff
I keep wanting to do I think I put it in
the patreon poll a couple times but it
never won yeah because like because I
kept wanting to because I saw it it was
on like 2B or something yeah I remember
liking it but I haven't seen it in a
long time
crawl and there was another one I
remember crawl having like some pretty
cheesy special effects but maybe I'm
remembering it wrong man had the bad
guys they looked like a cross between
like the the xenomorph from Alien and a
knight and a robot and when you killed
them they had a little [__] jellyfish
alien pop out of their head and would
just jumping out of the sand and try to
get away gotta hate one so they were
kind of like a Mecca
they had a spirit shot the end of it out
it was kind of like a laser beam or
Crystal or something I don't remember
exactly what it was and some dude found
this damn
and he's like the like a Luke Skywalker
type guy found this throwing star like a
ninja throwing star that unfolded and
that that was like the force or
something yeah it's been a long time and
he had to have that thing to destroy
this [__] demon
that was taken over the planet I feel
like for whatever reason I might have
watched crawl like in the last year or
so I don't know what circumstances I
would have watched it by myself
I remember I saw it on the big screen a
couple times I just thought it was it
looked amazing
[Laughter]
man that's bad ass [__] and then certain
elements of the story didn't make any
sense I said man that's dumb and then
some other [__] that's some bad ass [__]
man it's just dumb
I'm so conflicted right yeah yeah yeah
but I saw it twice
Hugo brings up ladyhawk actually I don't
think we've ever covered ladyhawk have
we and I and I love that movie it sounds
familiar I love that movie that was
Michelle Pfeiffer and um and um and um
what's his name from The Hitcher God
damn it oh uh uh oh my God I spaced I
spaced what's his [__] name and he
was in power there you go the Rucker
Howard yeah and he was in it too that
yeah that was really good also a fantasy
um and Legend was really good like oh
like I said there was a lot of good
fantasy moves fantasy isn't my main like
I said I'm more like a pure horror
person but I did like some of the
fantasy movies from the 80s Ben says I
think all the TV show episodes are now
free to watch on YouTube the first two
seasons are a bit rough they had no
writer's Bible for the first season so
there were a few famous contradictions
yeah I think that was like before they
had that whole thing where you had [__]
to like refer back to it's like hey you
don't [__] this up this is this is the
rules you know what I mean uh Hawk the
Slayer that movie is
awful yeah it sounds familiar I want
well I watched the rift tracks version
what was the one with the dude that had
the damn [__] ferrets Beastmaster no
yeah it was Beast yeah it's like a Conan
type of ripoff he had these two ferrets
in a bag and they go out and do [__]
I don't remember that I have two parrots
in a Bag Man the ferrets were kind of
like that they were kind of the comedian
yeah I thought that was Beastmaster
right might have been
yeah that was Beastmaster Beastmaster
the master beaster
[Laughter]
master
heart Jaguar said yeah Liam Neeson is in
crawl that's right yes yeah he was he
was young I think yeah I gotta see that
again now Ben said what were the ferrets
called zippo and Zappo yeah I don't know
I haven't seen Beastmaster in a long
time I saw all of these movies like back
in the 80s because all we did back in
the 80s was sit around like watching
cable you know what I mean like after
school and so you would just watch
whatever was on what she saw the fan
yeah it's okay
Help
looked up the fan and yelled at it
you're so weird okay
I saw a Beastmaster in the theater did
you really yeah because
Summer's summertime seeing my dad in
Mississippi he'd go to Sawmill Square
Mall down in Laurel it was only a place
to really go and uh they had matinees
and they it wasn't expensive you could
see a movie back then I think for like
three bucks
if I remember correctly in the 80s it
was like three dollars
I used to go to the budget theater where
like the set was the second round movies
and it was a dollar yeah they had dollar
movies too yeah and I think the new ones
you could see them from the matinee I
think was like three bucks yeah and uh
they had it damn uh
a a an arcade a stand-up console games
which those are gone now but there's
[__] badass arcade for the time
called Aladdin's what was that Aladdin
something or other met
Ric aladdins or something magic
Aladdin's Castle okay that's castle
that's what it's called and you could uh
you get to you get tokens from the token
machine
man I [__] saw the thing there
[__] aliens
but yeah Beastmaster crawl
I saw this one there
Blade Runner saw it there
uh yeah
um that would have that would have been
what 83 82.
yeah yeah that was 82 I think 82 yep
what are you doing back there she's
trying to make noise okay Ben says you
laugh but remember the guy next to you
in the Walmart queue might be a human
shell controlled by a little squidgy
magic yeah yeah you never know you look
like a little if I remember I remember
what it looked like it looked like a
little Scorpion or something
and he's in there like driving jump out
of his head and [__] try to go away
okay run away down to the ground we can
go back and get another body and come
back
that's yeah okay
hard Jaguar said you're the hunter from
the future yeah didn't okay oh remember
yeah I kind of remember I did not have
the guy like the big Italian wouldn't it
didn't I have the big chunk head guy
that was in space Mutiny I don't know
what the [__] is that dude's name red
Brown
the one that they made if you guys are
Mystery Science Theater fans like space
no that was uh that's Robert zadar oh
God but how do I know
I know all the actors that were on MST
movies because I've seen them so many
times he's got a whole catalog of freaky
[__] off of cheap movies yeah
how does like it takes up probably like
85 of my brain is taken up with like
shitty boobies because I've seen them
like on MST so many times and they have
so many like jokes about them but the
reason it's like so I can't take I think
it's you're the hunter from the future
it's one of those kind of like sword and
sandal like Conan rip-offs that came out
in the 80s and one of them has red Brown
in it and uh red Brown was in space
Mutiny which is one of the word I think
it was made in South Africa actually and
it was kind of like a Battle Star
Galactica I think it even used footage
from Battlestar Galactica like illegally
yeah like without just like well we
don't need permission to use this we're
in South Africa yeah they're in South
Africa you could probably you probably
couldn't sue them there yeah under their
legal [__] structures probably not
they're just like working we're gonna
make a whole entire movie out of your
movie turkey was doing it that's true
turkey ripoff Spielberg and [__] clips
from [__] Star Wars they're putting
it in their movies although they were
never they never got a good like it's
it's like they went into the theater
like with a with an old Super 8 camera
like under their coat like filming it
surreptitiously and then stuck in it
it's like it just doesn't fit with the
other stealing tens of millions of
dollars worth of special effects with a
little [__] handheld film Super Eight
camera I kind of feel like that's a tape
recorder and then you put that in there
I gotta feel like [__] turkey had no
shame man
I feel like a lot of countries are like
well why spend millions and billions of
dollars like to make these movies when
somebody else already and we could just
rip it off and just like throw in some
of our own [__] that we filmed in a
parking lot somewhere that's what
vaporwave was all about and people will
watch it that's what vaporwave is but
why why write a song there's so many
other songs that were already written
just steal a little bit of that song
slow it down and just play it repeat it
over and over again that's your song
reuse man recycled music sure I mean you
know yeah it's just laying around
there's no reason to change to write a
new song
it's too hard too hard man
I don't mind like stuff being remixed
and stuff like that because some people
like do their own kind of thing with it
but yeah I do kind of it is kind of like
funny
the way they just kind of like take what
was that it sounded like you farted
[Laughter]
farting on no I didn't I said I said
chair sounded like that it's the uh
bottom of that Rubber Sole okay Rubber
Soul yeah here that's a famous album
here
foreign
[Laughter]
look I gotta make a shirt all right okay
hold on hold on uh Zach says red Brown
no it's actually Reb with a B red but
Brown because he said did the movie also
Star as sister blue pink and their mom
orange green yeah but uh yeah so
Highlander
uh if you have not seen it it came out
like I said in 86 and if you really like
fantasy movies from that time period
it's um it's it's pretty cool it's like
it's a good concept and it's a cult
classic for a reason
um I don't really know I haven't seen
the sequels in a really long time I've
seen the second one but it was so long
ago that I don't remember it and a lot
of people really hate it so I don't
really know I might eventually get into
like watching the series because a lot
of people thought that was really good
but you know because a lot of people
like that yeah we got so much [__] to
watch though but that's what I mean it's
just like ah there's just so much
content out there now that it's just
kind of like I'm so so behind on
everything like movies series books I'll
just never live long enough like to see
or read everything that I want to see or
read which really blows but yeah so um
okay so we're gonna wrap it up because
we've been on for about an hour and we
have to make a t-shirt for uh Amanda who
I think was here earlier uh so we're
gonna get that done and so we can get it
maybe mailed out in the morning so so
yeah tomorrow is Monday so we're going
to be doing a haunting Mondays and we're
going to be doing another season one
episode I thought we had done all the
season one episodes but apparently we
didn't because we haven't done season
one episode eight which is called the
Diabolical so that's the one that we're
going to be doing tomorrow if you would
like to watch ahead of time uh so yeah
it'll probably be I think it'll be 7 30
p.m Eastern Standard time tomorrow
evening we're going to be doing haunting
so we will see you guys then have a good
rest of your weekend and we'll see you
guys again tomorrow evening good night